bill macaley 52 years old former naval
officer once athletically inclined
formerly a vigorous and active man today
bill finds himself winded after half a
block's walk so short of breath he must
stop to rest before continuing the rest
of the way
by the time he reaches his car he is so
out of breath that he needs a whiff of
oxygen to bring him back to normal
frank ussery former construction worker
spent his spare time hunting and fishing
today the act of shaving a routine and
effortless task to most men taxes him so
that he has to stop frequently to catch
his breath even though he sits and leans
on the sink to conserve his energy
harry kraus formerly a farmer has to go
through this process four times each day
to clear his lungs of accumulated fluids
so he can lead a very limited existence
comfortably
these men share in common with an
estimated 13 million americans a
disabling disease that can make every
breath of air they draw a major effort
they have emphysema
when emphysema strikes the act of
breathing and involuntary function to
healthy people becomes hard work
sometimes demanding most of the strength
the body can muster leaving its victims
gasping for air
emphysema victims often find themselves
drowning in a sea of air unable to
obtain the life-supporting oxygen their
systems require
to bill macalely and his family this is
an ever-present threat
we've been to the grocery store and
i went after the car it was about to
rain
and i picked him up the door and he had
two fairly heavy bags of groceries which
he lifted into the car and
i guess that was it it just took his
breath completely and i'd forgotten to
put the little ball of oxygen we
normally carry into the car we drove out
here i thought i might have to run him
by the hospital before we got here but
he got his breath all right
we made it but that was one of the worst
times i've seen him have lately
maybe it was the humidity you never
really know
probably
it's real frightening not to be able to
get your breath
uh i have a tank tank at home i have a
tank out here with a face mask regulator
i have a ball of oxygen that i take in
the car with me so that wherever i go i
have access to the oxygen
and i don't need it every day but the
fact that it's there gives me uh
self-assurance gives me confidence that
if something should happen i have the
oxygen available and that does as much
for me possibly is the oxygen itself
and of course i've learned to live we
have learned to live with this but at
first
i was scared to death frankly all the
time uh
when i when mac would leave the house
i would be like this until he got back
because i was just sure he was gonna die
before he would get back in fact i
uh worried myself into a nice little
ulcer during that period but
then gradually we learned what emphysema
was
and how it affected the person and what
we had to do to learn to live with it so
i'd say we've improved considerably in
that direction too
uh i look big and strong and healthy but
i can't take physical exertion so if
people look at me rather funny when i'm
walking along and she's carrying the bag
or when we come up to the door and she
lets me out and then she walks back
uh
that makes a makes it kind of
embarrassing
and i attempt to cover that in many ways
by stopping and resting or stopping and
looking at something and just not seeing
her doing these things
a lot of times i do that
uh bill has taken over a lot of their
she has taken over a lot of it i don't
do anything very much anymore that
requires physical exertion
uh that's probably one of the things
that uh bothers me most
i could do a lot of these things at one
time and now i can't and
uh it's a rather frustrating experience
it's sometimes disillusioning to think
that well sure i can do this and then i
find that i can't i have to quit
and this is one of the substitutes
that i found to make bedspreads and
tablecloths placemats
uh afghans
they are a lot of things that can be
done
that would take away energy that i
expended in athletic contests
or events prior to this that i now have
to do
something that doesn't take that much
physical exertion
the absence of oxygen
makes me tired very easily and many
times i come home from school
put on my pajamas have dinner go right
to bed because that's the only energy
that i have and by doing that i can
teach whereas if i tried to do a lot of
other things and i couldn't i'd just be
completely out completely without energy
he's he's learned to conserve himself
for the jobs that he wants to do and
wants you know enjoys doing and can do
he spends many weekends in bed too but
that's fine that by doing that he's able
to go to school
what does bill suspect is the cause of
his disease
possibly smoking
and the fact that i
uh well we don't know for sure
i had pneumonia twice and i smoked
heavily
so they don't know whether the smoking
caused it or whether the pneumonia
caused me to have emphysema but the
theory is that smoking heavy smoking
costs
despite his father's condition and
suspicion bill jr smokes
i
thought about quitting a couple of times
but uh i never have gotten around to it
and uh
i don't smoke in front of him
often uh sometimes when we play cards
and we're together for long periods of
time i
have one in front of him but uh
i don't know sometimes when i've done
something
active like uh
i play football and bowl things like
that sandlot and
when i get short of breath it makes me
wonder sometimes you know if i might
have it or something like that
and at those times particularly i think
about quitting but uh
in fact i did quit for about a month
but i couldn't lose
the desire
enough how much do you smoke
oh anywhere from a half a pack to a pack
a day i don't smoke heavily yet
and nowhere near as heavily as he used
to smoke
he'll have it though
i really think he will he has some of
the same
symptoms already that his father has
sniffly knows and
they both get sneezing
spells i'll call them and they'll sneeze
15 or 20 times and then they'll end up
with a cold
and bill does that so he's very much
like his father in a number of ways as
you can see
i really think
he's a good
suspect
prospect then well i wish he would quit
the same way probably that my father
wished that i would quit uh i think i
have more visible evidence though of
what it could do to you than
uh than i had from my father so i wish
he would quit because i think it would
be to his advantage not only from a
health standpoint but from a monetary
standpoint because it's expensive to
smoke as well as being a health hazard
although there is no known cure for
emphysema certain infrequent cases may
be given some relief through surgery
harry krause is a case in point he knew
the operation was very risky but felt he
had nothing to lose i was no good to
myself or anybody else i couldn't take a
bath myself or anything else and i
required help to do everything and
it was a living death if you want to put
it like that
according to dr thomas d bartley the
surgeon who performed the operation
harry krause's specific condition
warranted the surgery
similar situation is depicted here in
this whole lung section prepared
at the research center in jacksonville's
baptist memorial hospital
the upper part of this love
has been destroyed by emphysema
the lower parts
are
have disease in them as shown in these
enlightened areas here
however there is enough preservation of
the normal architecture
so that one
could guess that removal of this part
which is over inflated and compressing
or squashing the more normal areas
might result
in
improved function within this lung
this of course
occurred
in mr krause's situation
and
though he was
totally disabled prior to his operation
he has been able to return to
a relatively normal level
of activity
although surgery did improve harry's
condition emphysema still forces him to
lead a very limited life
i've turned the entire business set up
over to her
and however i am able to help in an
advisory capacity
i can do no work at all i can't lift
anything uh trying to
agitates it and then you get clear down
to where you can't even take care of
yourself and it takes you a long time to
build back up and get the
stamina that
you wouldn't have if you didn't try it
walking too fast too far targets you out
any carrying and even the extent of five
pounds in your hands charge you out
right now because
uh in my condition right now it
overloads me i can carry the weight that
i've got if i'm very very careful but if
i add anything to it like a heavy
overcoat or a big pair of boots or
something like that it wears you out
oh you have to
do a lot of extra work and
things that he can't do and
all the
taking care of him when he is
down
to live with emphysema the crosses have
had to make many adjustments
just don't go anymore or do things that
you used to do for pleasure you know
it's uh
staying home practically all the time
you don't have any social life all the
friends that you had you used to go out
with an evening and things like that
they drift away
knowing the condition and everything you
have friends that drop in on the end
your close relations stick by you but
that's the extent of your social life
you
lose all contact of it because
you just can't go in public places with
anything like this the doctors advise
against it because coals are transmitted
and if i get one
i'm in trouble
for a man who formerly led an active
life slowing down to almost a standstill
has its obvious problems yes i was
active all my life in fact we built this
place here ourselves
and
all the hard work is in it we put in it
and
we've been that way all of our life
we've worked hard and
had to work you might say for what we've
got
that's the hardest thing for somebody's
got a lot of ambition to keep from doing
is overdoing with something like this
because
if you overdo it
uh you set yourself back to where you
can't even get around you just gotta
quit everything and go in complete grass
in his battle to breathe harry must go
through an exhausting effort to clear
the fluid from his respiratory system
four times each day
we take the machine for approximately a
half an hour
and that it has medicine in it and we
fill our lungs with that machine
and then after that we get down on the
floor and my wife pushes on my
one side and the other side and then my
back
so it was the cause you have to see
i believe the cause i'm sure the cause
was cigarettes
oh how was it
well one time i smoked about four pack a
day
and towards the last it was too regular
i guess that's partly my trouble if i
hadn't smoked at that time probably it
wouldn't been as bad on me but
you just don't do those things of course
in those days you didn't know
what cigarettes was going to do to you
in later life
but now they're beginning to find out
for frank ussery almost totally
incapacitated by emphysema for the past
four years the routine task of shaving
is a major physical effort
well the obsession will go through with
that record i just get out of breath and
i shave it
and uh
i don't have the strength to sit out and
stand up to shave i give out my leg give
out on me
and i sit on that stool it's not so
comfortable i guess i'm too high or
something
and uh of course if i take my arms and
live on the sink or something and use
one hand at the time
it's not quite so bad it's but it takes
strength
just moving my arms around
i think take strength and
i don't have too much of it i guess so
that's i get tired nicely
i just while i'm shaving i take time
once a while resting for a
few seconds 10 15 20 seconds 30 seconds
and then start again i get my way that
way
and exertion
takes all my strength away from it what
for instance what kind of exertion
well walking or
walking mostly just walking because
that's about only like i do i wouldn't
have any energy enough to do any kind of
work
uh
i don't even write the letters anymore
dressing ties me
stepping over to put all my socks on my
shoes
standing up put on my pants and bend
around putting my shirt on
well
if i do it if i do it slowly i can
gradually go ahead probably take me
three or four five minutes to get my
transmission on
and then i won't be out of breath when i
get it on
but then when i walk from uh the bedroom
into the kitchen
uh i couldn't begin to start drinking
coffee right then
because my business was short i just
haven't got breath in that got to worry
about me to eat
even uh
particularly eating face to try to shoot
face
it actually ties in to talk too long
well the word removes that i can't get
out and do the things that i'd like to
do
just cooped up in the house all the time
uh i can't even drive a car anymore
he was power steering i only have a
strength huh
these are just ripping down the car and
tired me out
we've always
enjoyed going on trips so much
and uh
we all
used to love to visit our neighbors
and now that's
impossible we don't even get to go to
church together
i have to go to the church service in
the morning and then come home and
listen to 11 o'clock service was fine
just seeing him this way is just the
most tragic thing to me
but um
and then i used to depend on him so much
to do things for me
and they came dry dishes
and uh
i think that's meant a lot
in our lives it's just the
idea he just cannot do things for
himself or for me either one or for
anybody else
and he's always been so active and
fished and hun
everything like that but
they just
he loves to read and look at the tv but
that's about the only thing recreation
that he gets
if i should want to go get in the car
and walk to the car if i walk real slow
and i do a whole lot better if i try to
walk the face of the car of town get out
there i'd be so completely out of breath
i can hardly catch my breath
frank's condition causes his wife a
great deal of apprehension
and then it's always so frightening to
me at night when
i'm here all by myself with him and i'm
always so afraid he's going to get sick
during the night
but so far he's
done pretty well
but
i think that's enough and it's
it's been worrying me it's just
i did it he might need me during the
night and i would know it
frank too cites cigarettes as the
probable cause of his emphysema
i was spoken serious and i guess uh
like nine percent i might say these
cigarettes i guess called me short of
breath but i wouldn't quit smoking
that's just
not possible like the average man would
i don't know
there is still a great deal to be
learned about emphysema
at the university of florida medical
center and other hospitals throughout
the country intensive research is
underway to develop a cure for this
disease whose victims are increasing in
alarming proportions
social security disability payments to
emphysema patients ranks second only to
those made to people disabled by heart
disease
under laboratory conditions the effect
of emphysema on work capacity can be
carefully measured
we're following mr usury's heart rate
and breathing rate as he recovers from
an exercise load
his ability to exercise against
a known load
is approximately half a normal person's
ability
his emphysema
has
caused this
and is shown by a rapid breathing rate
even three to five minutes after he
stopped pedaling
emphysema such as mr ussery has is a
disease of the lungs
caused by
bronchitis
a narrowing of the small airways
and also
a destruction of the lung tissue itself
the bronchitis or the obstruction part
causes the lungs to over inflate they
balloon up so that a patient is forced
to breathe
on top of them so to speak
if we look here we can see how a normal
person breathes quietly
and then when he takes in a deep breath
he can bring in
up to three liters
or over three quarts of air and blow out
rapidly almost five
but a person with emphysema
is starting at a high point
in his lung volume and he can only take
in
one or two quarts
and worst of all he can
blow out only slowly
two or three quarts of air
now the diffusion the way the tissue of
the lungs take up oxygen and put it into
the bloodstream that courses through the
lungs from the air that a person
breathes is important
and a normal person's value might be
twenty
a patient such as mr usri has destroyed
much of his lung tissue and can take up
only half as much as a normal can
when a person can't breathe deeply and
can't exhale rapidly he becomes
desperately short of breath
he can't work
he is in trouble at home just getting
around a house
his ability to support his family is
ruined
we can't cure emphysema we can help
patients that have it
they should not give up hope we can
get them to quit smoking
and guarantee a certain return
in their ability to work
we can also use medicines such as
adrenaline
for them to breathe
and
dilate those small bronchial tubes
we give them exercises for posture and
to help them bring up
the secretions out of their lungs
many health authorities still refer to
emphysema's cause as unknown
increasingly however researchers are
placing the lion's share of the blame on
a single
the
source
way
to
get rid of emphysema is not treatment
it's to
teach children
that the long-term effects of cigarette
smoking is very dangerous to their
health
mark twain once observed that each
person is born with one possession which
out values all his others his last
breath
emphysema victims have gone mark twain
one better
in their day-in day-out battle to keep
their lungs working they have come to
cherish not just their last breath
but they're every breath
so
you